okay well magnus being magnus what a  neat move because the whole idea there  was that uh  now magnus can simply play rook takes  bishop  once the king moves and it's going to  game game over  yup that was a sadistic idea by magnus  taking off that bishop  um he could have just pushed his ball  but he says no let's get that bishop off  and bishop versus knight in this end  game  that we're about to see the bishop is  dominant and black still has that  powerful pawn about to become a queen  erroneou resigns wow it's over magnus  carlsen the winner of game  three uh in the semi-final second match  against levon ironian  taking the lead and this means  levonorony and he has to win the final  game to take it  to tie breaks how happy do you think  magnus is feeling now ivanka  he's he must be really really ecstatic  because you know he's put behind the  disaster  that was the game too where he was  winning  and then he played a few careless moves  and before he knew it he